france et de leadership en matière de
défense et j'espère que ça va se passer
dans les six mois qui viennent ça va
vous faire plaisir d'entendre ça que la
france est le leadership en matière de
déficit oui et non mais je pense qu'on
est tous conscients que aujourd'hui
singulièrement après le départ du
royaume uni de l'union européenne la
france objectivement et la principale
puissance militaire d'europe qui en plus
une gamme complète y compris avec la
dissuasion nucléaire ce qui est tout à
fait singulier pour pour l'europe donc
la france est naturellement j'allais
dire dans un siège de conducteur pour
l'europe de la défense puis ça
correspond à une vieille aspiration
française pour autant ça nous oblige à
nous français un grand travail de
conviction vis-à-vis de nos partenaires
et parfois je trouve que ce travail est
fait avec un peu trop d'arrogance parce
que on se satisfait d'être dans la
position de leader et on a envie
d'imposer sa à tout le monde et on pense
que c'est une évidence pour tout le
monde et je crois qu'il faut qu'on soit
un peu plus modeste dans notre message
adressé notamment au président de l'afic
française emma n'est pas bon merci à
tous les deux d'être venu à sur notre
plateau
[Musique]